percentage increase and decrease this is
something which particularly we're going
to be doing a lot with money okay and
this is something which you'll be doing
all the time you walk through the
shopping aisle and it's like okay it's
10% off or 20% off or you can get an
extra 50% on this new biggest size pack
all those kinds of things right so
really quickly let's have a look at some
of these questions together and they're
very very concrete practical we'll start
with one aim okay so if you haven't ever
eaten a beautiful corner you can do that
and let's use these desire examples one
day the question is I'll just shut down
the question because you might not have
it in front of you right now
it's increase so what is first one
increase $150 why five percent I'm gonna
teach you two ways to do this okay and
I'm lucky to get down both ways of
working out and then you can kind of
choose which one you prefer but you
really should know how both of them work
because they're kind of useful in their
own situations so we know how to do
percentages of a quantity already so if
I just slightly change to the question
to show you my first approach what would
5% how do I calculate five percent of a
hundred fifty hands up you would tell me
what should I write yet okay so I can do
150 okay now I'll have to bring in the
five but be careful because if I do over
that'll be division right so I don't do
to your five would tell me okay if I
take my hundred fifty dollars and I put
it into five equal piles or gave it to
five people how much would each get
right now I would get a number for that
I'm not sure if I would get five percent
three hmm leapin um yeah yeah okay what
am I gonna do with 500 all right all
right down 500 500 but what am I gonna
do with that
I'll get to the second we started this
fight how I got it yes okay good I'm
gonna your time's right so this is gonna
give me five percent of 150 okay this is
um how much increase there is so like
you know I can quickly work this out you
can either do this with your calculator
or you might be able to the nose is not
that hard
does anyone think they can do it in
their head five percent one hundred
fifty yep yeah yep what's the extra
what's the extra yeah what's this great
sir seven or sixty so this is how much
we're going to increase by now I have
that number but I still have my original
hundred fifty right so therefore I would
say it's a equals take your 150 add the
extra amount and there's your answer
finished are you happy with that it's
logical right ah that's a great question
okay so why is it over 100 and not 150
very good question
where I pull you back to is this guy
here all of us what does that symbol
mean again it means yeah it's percent
percent which literally means out of 100
life sentence in century hundred years
yeah so therefore it's always gonna be
out of a hundred no matter if this is
350 or 1500 or a million the percent
part means out of 100 so there we go
that's that makes sense well how do you
like okay I'll come later baby
all right I guess later there's method
one okay here I'm just going to put the
same question but another way of
approaching it okay I'm going to still
start with 150 but this time see how got
kind of two steps to this I've got work
out the extra bit and then add it
yeah combine it okay I'm gonna try and
do all of those steps at once right I'm
gonna do this 150 I'm still gonna
multiply right but do you see increasing
hundred fifty dollars by five percent is
exactly the same as taking a hundred and
five percent of my original amount let
me say that again kitchen ketchup adding
five percent right is the same as saying
well there's a hundred percent and
there's five percent 100 percent five
percent so altogether I've got a hundred
and five percent does that make sense
and if I was increasing by twenty you'd
be 120 percent or front so increasing by
a hundred and be two hundred percent
right so here I'm going to multiply and
I'm gonna multiply by instead of five
hundred in five okay so that's my one
hundred and five percent okay so in some
ways this is doing this pot of five and
the original pot which is a hundred
percent all at the same go just out of
curiosity you have to write this pot but
this is the same as 1 point or five in
your calculator can verify that for you
and move the decimal place when you
divide by 100 and your calculator will
give this to you in one hit you can go
ahead you can punch it in x 1.25 and
because it's the same question you're
going to get the same on top okay any
questions on that method one you've
worked out the increase method to you
just do it all in one hit this is ever
so slightly quicker isn't it right
because we're doing one step instead of
two but either one is fine either one
will land you at the right answer
because they're both different ways of
getting to the same place yes
yeah so this makes it a little bit
trickier if you like well okay maybe if
they ask a different question you want
to go back to this way of doing it which
is why it's really important you've got
both written down okay yes yeah okay if
you don't have a calculator or if later
on you want to be practicing how to do
it without a calculator my brain can't
keep such big numbers in my head right
so I would go back to this way I think
this way keeps less than your head think
about this part here mmm
how do we do this part here let's come
back another come on okay you've got 150
times now see how it's 5 over 100 right
I'm gonna do this in two steps just to
break it down for my brain because it's
simpler that way I'm gonna do the 1 over
100 first and then I'm gonna do the 5
can you see that this this is the same
as this they are the same yeah I guess
let's do one step at a time
150 I'm gonna multiply it by 100 that's
the same as dividing by a hundred right
so when you're divided by tens or
hundreds or thousands you can just move
the decimal place back and forth right
so should I move the decimal place it's
there should I move it that way to the
left or should I move it to the right
this way what do you think hmm when I
divide by a hundred should I move it to
this right it's to the left here's how I
know right
suppose I'm like I can't remember which
way it is I'll just try moving out one
way and see how we go if I move it to
the right I move to the right twice
because it's two zeroes right I move it
to the right I'm going to get one five
zero zero zero and there's my new
decimal place does that look like it's
you know one percent all of 150 that's
ridiculous it's bigger it's big I've
gone the wrong way okay so that's how I
know I should go
not that way but that way like you
suggested I should have one dollar 50
I've moved it twice can you see that and
I've still got the x 5 on the end okay
now five times
point-five you could sort of do that
part in your head dollar fifty three
dollars or dollars fifty help me out
what's next hold on
four dollars fifty add another dollar
fifty six dollars and then last one
seven dollars fifty and that's what
lands me yeah okay and obviously if you
do have a calculator you can still do
this and then check it to make sure you
got the right answer